hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the thing
that's door slammed so I'm gonna
investigate oh that's the key right here
with Allah Bhushan I don't know what
came over me right there so I apologize
for whatever that was
I'm going crazy it's a little late I'm
tired and I don't usually drink caffeine
but I kind of took a Red Bull or you
know take red jected thread pull right
into my arteries no I drank a Red Bull
and I don't usually drink caffeine so
I'm kind of so if I seem a little crazy
you know wonder with this rolled rusty
key goes to some sort of Easter Egg oh
sorry I'm done with that that's stupid
unless you guys like that voice which I
don't you do oh that's gender my
boo-boos yeah got it
alright
[Music]
I hear that
are not hear that - rumbling I can't
hide anything for me I'm very observant
about this stuff okay hammer doesn't
help me at all
why are we doing why are we doing this
why are we here I can't we all just get
along why does everything have to be so
damn murdery Oh
open up are you son of a [ __ ] are you
for the rusty key nope I don't have any
place to hide ah excuse me if the firing
rods go bad you can find them here in
the cellar one is always in my locked
desk drawer but I've lost the key
before I could remember where I've
hidden the spare keys years ago now that
I think about it I think it is in a high
place you'll have to get all three in
place for the machine to fire off will
fire off on its own and do an auto start
if you can't find all the rods in this
room just ask maintenance where the rest
of them are so I did find the key
okay there we go hey get out of there
get out of there now there ah oh oh
throw something boom do something useful
don't kill me bro what's going back he's
actually going back ha does coming hard
I can see his legs his legs ain't so
fine oh I wish my statue girlfriend
we're here sorry buddy you ain't sexy no
I know how hard you try to strut your
stuff you is not look blood okay I think
I can get at this stuff I'm just very
very careful about myself walk nice nice
didn't stick the landing but it was nice
I don't know how to get back
[Music]
oh by the way that voice I did really
was supposed to be like my you know my
old western compadre you know the
sidekick and Western go cuz I'm from
grub oh no ok nevermind yeah you don't
know what I'm talking about
I'll never bust it out again that's
where I'm so sorry about subjecting you
to that I could have sworn it was gonna
be an easter egg again no it's like no
oh it's part of the story you're just
really good finding stuff man if I
didn't find that that would have taken
forever but my gamer instinct kicked in
and I knew it was supposed to be go up
okay is he gone yet
Hey okay okay now I've got one rod
and I need to find two others an
unmarked key for the seller okay I think
I got all the doors down here so I'm
pretty sure I can move on now
there wasn't any door here oh yes oh
that's the end result that's what I'm
supposed to go after I get the Trinity
rods they're not the Eternity roads
they're not the Trinity rod system
oh god something is coming
it sounds so what is the bathroom is not
the high tea room I'm gonna hide behind
these barrels that were so suspiciously
placed I got to rebuild the barrier
perfect
you'll never know maybe one more so
skillful
and you'll never know huh damn
I heard the I heard the squeal for a
second there you can't find me I'm
behind barrels that's right I see you
know I'm not looking at you directly so
I'm not going insane give me yeah it's
bad idea ah all right that didn't work
at all
where to go where did you
ah he's on the wrong side I think I can
probably sneak bastard
nobody's going back I'll just be right
here by my potatoes different hands oh
you got some beautiful hands okay I
think he's just patrolling that area so
I could probably behind here maybe or
maybe this is where I die again
why no no no no I'm not their door looks
really old
I need to find a crowbar or a hammer
okay all right whatever aah I messed up
I done goofed
I didn't expect him to be right there
why was he he was like walking at the
exact same pace I was totes not totes
not the hot what's not in a ha moment
that's all
oh this map maker is diabolical
oh but seriously this map maker deserves
all the highest of high schools good man
I need to get up there inconspicuous
reasons locked hey lady there's really
nothing I can do to help you
ah there we go slow psycho trinity
triangle no cycle circle I remember from
people yelling at me when I first played
amnesia because I didn't get that I know
I did when I first played amnesia I'm
pretty sure you guys watched all I did
was I inserted them until it got right
so I just brute force through it which
was bad apparently and everyone hated me
for crash that's why think of your jet
that's right [ __ ] off tinderbox
oh I'm sorry could you come back I'm
sorry I didn't mean
I didn't mean to do that anything else
Anu oh yeah that was in here that's
right I just didn't want to go in there
for obvious reasons hiding place maybe
behind here there's a lot of boxes
I gotta stop doing it the ambient noises
are getting to me
another an English perfect Galloway sure
you check these drawers prints and also
oil because I'm almost out no I said I'm
okay
chairs having a little powwow back here
[Music]
don't know why I trusted you chairs in
the first place your never know dead
mani good and then you stopped hurting
the monsters and then you let them get
me
you just kind of shrugged off their
shoulders and we're like oh yeah he's
over there get him don't think I don't
know ah stop it
haunted rugs unmatching coats smash come
on run out of oils for serious bang so
dirty
ah crowbar oh god yeah I don't have a
key for you
nope okay that doors gonna stay locked
unless it bursts open with a monster
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
aha what done no there we go sorry
ah boom right off its hinges to pieces
even so strong all right I'm almost out
of oil - again seller that doesn't seem
good why call it the deep seller I don't
like the sound of that get real deep
back in that cellar yeah oh no no no oh
no I see you what do you do nothing oh
no no no water part not water I hate
water
oh I hate water in man
Hey look fishy but another fishy in this
game almost makes me feel safe but not
really oh this was a mistake okay here
we go
this just seems like a mistake seems
like a very large mistake seems like the
worst mistake of my life I feel like I'm
going in a circle
I am this is why just a way for me to
get killed
yeah yeah oh this is where I need to cut
the did the acid need something to melt
it ah I see
well now let's see if we can do
something about that but forest to
explore
why I don't really know but I need to
a mixture for an acid goodie
okay I'm guessing the other mixer isn't
gonna be relocated ah okay whatever
all right so I'm a double check okay I
don't want to be running back here gin
case I missed something so it's
definitely not around here and it's not
okay so since I don't have the other
part I'll just have to look elsewhere
for tea I should have been I should have
been trying to keep an eye out for it
before but I totally forgot about the
acid that I needed for something that I
had never seen before my mistake my bad
guys my bad
get out of here I know there's gonna be
a water monster there I know there has
to be it's like guaranteed where's all
this slime coming from yo mama yeah yeah
it's kind of sad his mom might be dead
yeah any second now actually I'm out of
time so I'll do my outro other slowing
thank you all so much for watching hope
you all enjoyed it and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]